التشريع الاردني يمنع الزواج كليا قبل
بلوغ سن الرشد المعتمد 18 عاما ولكنه في
الوقت ذاته سمح بالزواج في سن 16 في حالات
خاصه واذا سوف جمله من الشروط وتشمل الفئه
العمريه لزواج القاصرات ما بين 18 الى 15
عاما حيث يبلغ عدد زوج القاصرات في الاردن
بين 11 او حتى عشره الاف سنويا في دراسه
اعدتها منظمته السيد
فقط من الاناث التي تمت مقابلتهن انهن
وصلنا تعليمهن بينما تسرب 92% منهم وكان
سبب الاكبر الذي تم الاستشهاد به للتسرب
للمدرسه هو مسؤوليات الزواج بنسبه
46% يليها رفض الزوج بنسبه 13% وعدم
الاهتمام بمواصله التعليم بنسبه 12% وفي
الوقت نفسه ذكرت الدراسه انه عند سؤال
القاضي عما اذا كان قد طلب تاكيدات بان
الفتاه ستواصل تعليمها بعد الزواج اشار
اربعه وثمانون في المائه الى ان القاضي لم
يطلب اي ضمانات